In these dark, and confusing, and combative times, where in just one month-- and it's a month that doesn't feel that atypical-- we have impeachment hearings, and Australia on fire, and a near war with Iran, and a deadly virus spreading around the world. We thought here at our show, we would try the most radical counter-programming possible. So today, we bring you our show about delight. And our story starts with my co-worker Bim Adewunmi, growing up in East London, in Nigeria, learning about America from afar.
在这个黑暗、混乱、好斗的时代，仅仅一个月的时间——这一个月感觉并不那么反常——我们经历了弹劾听证会、澳大利亚的大火、与伊朗的准战争，以及一种致命病毒在世界各地的蔓延。我们节目组认为，我们应该尝试一种最激进的反向节目安排。所以今天，我们为你带来关于快乐的节目。我们的故事从我的同事Bim Adewunmi开始，她在东伦敦和尼日利亚长大，从远处了解美国。
I just remember the feeling of swimming in a lot of American culture. I watched a lot of sitcoms. I'd been watching Roseanne, I Dream of Jeannie, Family Matters.
我只记得沉浸在大量美国文化中的那种感觉。我看了很多情景喜剧。我看了《罗珊》（Roseanne）、《我梦见珍妮》（I Dream of Jeannie）、《凡人琐事》（Family Matters）。
It was a hodgepodge of Americana. A deep dive on Marilyn Monroe, but also the books of Maya Angelou, and also the Cosby spin-off show, A Different World.
那是美国文化的集大成。深入研究玛丽莲·梦露，也读玛雅·安杰洛的书，还有《考斯比一家》的衍生剧《A Different World》。
And I remember thinking, there are so many different types of black people, doing their own version of black people things, and that was really interesting to me.
我记得当时在想，有那么多不同类型的黑人，做着他们自己版本的黑人事情，这对我来说真的很有趣。
Bim knew there were problematic things about America, of course. Who didn't know that?
Bim当然知道美国有让人诟病的地方。谁不知道呢？
But at the time, I was like, yay! American pop culture. This is great. And I had such a fixed idea of America. There were a million high school movies and TV shows. I was like, oh, yeah. If I was to land in an American school today, I would know exactly what to do. I know the crowd I would fit in with. It was going to be proms. It was going to be malls. I know where the cafeteria is. I understand that gym is a place of hell. I understood everything around the idea of American school. I had a whole vision of myself and where I would fit in the hierarchy.
但当时，我就觉得，耶！美国流行文化。这太棒了。我对美国有一个固定的想法。有数百万部关于高中的电影和电视节目。我就想，哦，是的。如果我今天降落在美国的一所学校，我完全知道该怎么做。我知道我能融入哪一群人。会有毕业舞会。会有购物中心。我知道食堂在哪里。我明白健身房是个地狱般的地方。我理解关于美国学校的一切概念。我对自己的定位以及在等级制度中的位置有着完整的设想。
Seriously?
真的吗？
Absolutely. I'd be the semi-jock, because I used to run track at school. So I was like, semi-jock, but sensitive, theater child, but also everybody's friend.
绝对是。我会是半个运动员，因为我以前在学校跑田径。所以我当时想，半个运动员，但很敏感，是个戏剧孩子，也是每个人的朋友。
Yeah.
是的。
And I would be approachable by people who weren't as cool as me. I had a whole strategy planned out.
而且那些不如我酷的人也会愿意接近我。我制定了一个完整的策略。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I love that you totally pictured your American high school.
我喜欢你完全构想出你自己的美国高中生活。
I was going to be the everyman who was also very cool, incredibly bright, very beautiful, very popular, but wasn't conceited. It seemed a shame to waste all this knowledge that I had about how American society functions by me being in England. It was like, well, what good is all this knowledge here? If you have the knowledge, then you want to be tested. I wanted to be tested. And the only real test is to actually live in America. To live that life.
我要成为那个既非常酷、极其聪明、非常漂亮、非常受欢迎，但又不自负的普通人。我在英国浪费了我所掌握的关于美国社会如何运作的所有知识，这似乎是一种耻辱。就像是，好吧，这些知识在这里有什么用？如果你拥有这些知识，那么你就会想要被测试。我想要被测试。而唯一真正的测试就是真正地生活在美国。去过那种生活。
And so, when she was 19, after high school and before college-- they don't call it high school and they don't call it college where she's from-- she decided, I'm going to do it. I'm going to take the test. Live the dream. Go live in America. In fact, not just any old part of America, but a quintessentially American corner of America. And that's summer camp.
所以，当她19岁时，在高中毕业后、大学之前——她家乡不叫高中也不叫大学——她决定，我要去做。我要参加测试。活出梦想。去美国生活。事实上，不仅仅是美国任何一个普通的地方，而是美国最典型的角落。那就是夏令营。
Summer camp's an institution they didn't really have in either of the countries where she'd spent her childhood-- Nigeria and England. She was hired by a company that brings in teenagers from overseas to work as counselors, and she was assigned to a camp in a very un-British location-- just outside Santa Cruz, California.
夏令营是她在童年生活的两个国家——尼日利亚和英国——都没有真正拥有的机构。她被一家公司聘用，这家公司把国外的青少年带进来担任辅导员，她被分配到加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯外的一个非常不英式的地方的一个营地。
We were amongst redwoods, some of the most ancient most majestic things ever on the Earth. They've seen [BLEEP] dinosaurs. So we were between the redwoods and the ocean. And I was like, man! You just don't get vistas like this in East London. It felt so American to be in nature like this. And we were sleeping in cabins, and I was like, yeah, this is a camp, all right.
我们身处红杉林中，那是地球上最古老、最壮观的事物之一。它们见过恐龙。所以我们就在红杉林和海洋之间。我当时想，天哪！你在东伦敦可看不到这样的景色。在大自然中感觉太美国了。我们睡在木屋里，我当时想，是的，这确实是个营地。
In fact, over and over she found herself seeing and doing things that she'd only encountered in American pop culture. For instance, she ate at an old-fashioned diner, with round stools at a long table, and a waitress in a striped blouse who called her honey. Or there was the day that a guy in a grocery store aisle, a total stranger, hit on her, which she'd only seen on television, which apparently is not a thing British men do very much. And each time these things happened, it was exhilarating and surprising.
事实上，她一次又一次地发现自己看到并做了只有在美国流行文化中才遇到过的事情。例如，她在一家老式的餐厅吃饭，长桌边有圆凳，服务员穿着条纹衬衫叫她亲爱的。还有一天，在杂货店的过道里，一个完全陌生的人搭讪了她，她只在电视上见过这种事，这显然不是英国男人经常做的事情。每次这些事情发生时，都令人振奋和惊讶。
So one of the other counselors at camp, Laurel, invited us all to her parents place on Lake Tahoe. So we drove down in her car, which was a white El Camino truck, and she told us his name was Chester. And I thought, that's perfect. Chester. Chester the El Camino truck. Yes. At that point, I didn't know how to drive. I still don't know how to drive because I lived in London, and there's a fantastic tube, and buses, and whatever, and I walked everywhere--
所以营地的另一位辅导员Laurel邀请我们所有人去她父母在太浩湖的房子。我们开车去了，那是辆白色的El Camino卡车，她告诉我们他的名字叫切斯特（Chester）。我想，那太完美了。切斯特。切斯特那辆El Camino卡车。是的。那时，我还不会开车。我现在也不会开车，因为我住在伦敦，那里有很棒的地铁、公共汽车等等，我到处都是走路——
Whatever. I don't want to hear your British chauvinism of our American way of life.
随便吧。我不想听你对我们美国生活方式的英国沙文主义论调。
It was great. Oh, my god.
那太棒了。哦，我的天哪。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Anyway, we drove down to Tahoe. And on the way we had the windows down, we were playing loud music, we're wearing jeans cutoffs, and I remember thinking yet again, this moment of stark clarity, I was like, oh my god! This is America! I'm in a truck! We're on the road! The wind is in our hair! This is perfect! We're a bunch of girls laughing about whatever, and it's great. Like it was a performance, but I knew all the words.
总之，我们开车去了太浩湖。在路上，我们摇下车窗，播放着大声的音乐，穿着剪短的牛仔裤，我记得我再次有了这种强烈的清晰感，我心想，哦，我的天哪！这就是美国！我在一辆卡车里！我们在路上！风吹过我们的头发！这太完美了！我们这群女孩在谈笑风生，感觉棒极了。就像一场表演，但我知道所有的歌词。
So you guys are playing the radio. Are you singing along with the radio?
所以你们在放收音机。你们在跟着收音机唱歌吗？
Yes, classic road trip-style.
是的，经典的公路旅行风格。
And do you remember what songs?
你还记得是什么歌吗？
Oh, I do remember one song. Super girly. That was the year that Norah Jones' album Come Away With Me came out.
哦，我确实记得一首歌。超级少女心。那一年Norah Jones的专辑《Come Away With Me》发行了。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
I don't care what anyone says. That album is a banger. I love it still. Norah Jones' is just perfect. And I remember the lead song, "I Don't Know Why" was on the radio every single day. And I remember us singing it, the final bit where she sings (SINGING) my heart's in something, something, whatever. And then she says this great line-- (SINGING) and you'll be on my mind.
我不在乎别人怎么说。那张专辑太棒了。我至今仍然很喜欢它。Norah Jones简直完美。我记得主打歌《I Don't Know Why》每天都在收音机里播放。我记得我们跟着唱，在最后她唱（唱歌）my heart's in something, something, whatever。然后她说那句很棒的歌词——（唱歌）and you'll be on my mind。
And I remember we would sing that, and we'd put our hands to our chests, and we would extend our arms and be like, (SINGING) you'll be-- and we would all sing it.
我记得我们当时会唱那段，把手放在胸口，然后伸展双臂，就像（唱歌）you'll be——我们都会一起唱。
[MUSIC - "YOU'LL BE ON MY MIND" BY NORAH JONES]
[音乐 - Norah Jones的《YOU'LL BE ON MY MIND》]
And it was just this very romantic, very windswept-- it felt to me, again, like the perfect soundtrack to my American summer.
那感觉非常浪漫，非常狂野——对我来说，它感觉再次成了我美国夏天的完美配乐。
America is real.
美国是真实的。
America is real! I was like, oh, my god! American things are happening to me.
美国是真实的！我就像，哦，天哪！美国人的事情正在发生在我身上。
OK, so like I said at the beginning, our show today is about delight. And it was during that summer, Bim says, because it was so full of moments of delight, she started to really take notice of that feeling and think of it as a thing, a thing that you liked. It wasn't just enjoyable, she thought. That feeling seemed important somehow.
好的，正如我开头所说，我们今天的节目是关于快乐的。Bim说，就在那个夏天，因为它充满了快乐的时刻，她开始真正注意到那种感觉，并把它看作是一件事，一件你喜欢的事情。她说，这不仅仅是享受。那种感觉似乎很重要。
And I thought, OK, this feeling is something worth repeating. And the idea that you can go and look for delight and you might find it, was, I think, fully planted that summer.
我想，好的，这种感觉是值得重复的。而你可以去寻找快乐并可能找到它的想法，我想，在那年夏天完全扎根了。
In you?
在你心里？
In me, yeah. Like if I actively sought out delight, I might be able to find it and replicate it forever. So I thought, OK, we'll just keep doing that. That was a way of organizing my life.
在我心里，是的。就像如果我积极地寻求快乐，我就可能找到它并永远复制它。所以我心想，好的，我们就一直这样做。这成了我安排生活的一种方式。
By the way, a very un-British way to organize her life, Bim says, to embrace delight wholeheartedly and un-self-consciously.
顺便说一句，Bim说这是一种非常不英式的安排生活方式，即全心全意且毫不自知地拥抱快乐。
Fundamentally, I'm fighting against every urge in me, which is like, don't. Don't do that. Because I'm still British. I can't help that. So I'm always just thinking to myself, just going like, oh, is that too much? I feel very much like somebody's disapproving nanny. Stop that. That's too much emotion. You know, there's a reason why our national sound is a tut. [TUTS] Stop it.
从根本上说，我是在抗拒内心深处的每一个冲动，那就是，别那样做。别那样做。因为我还是英国人。我对此无能为力。所以我总是对自己想，就像说，哦，这太过分了吗？我觉得自己很像一个爱评头论足的保姆。停下。那是太多的情绪了。你知道，我们的民族之声是“啧”是有原因的。[啧啧] 停下。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's an admonishment. It's like, stop it, you know? There used to be a talk show, and the theme song was a little child singing in this very sing-songy voice-- (SINGING) it'll never work. It'll never work. And that is how I feel about most things.
那是一种告诫。就像是，停下，你知道吗？以前有个脱口秀节目，主题曲是一个小孩子用那种非常儿歌的声音唱着——（唱歌）it'll never work. It'll never work. 这就是我对大多数事情的感觉。
That would never be a show here.
那在我们这里永远不会成为一个节目。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But this kid just sang in a sole voice, and then a chorus of voices join and say, (SINGING) it will never work!
但这个孩子只是用独唱声音唱，然后一群声音加入说，（唱歌）it will never work!
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Every time I see it, I'm like, a-ha! That is the spirit of Britain.
每次我看到它，我都会想，啊哈！那就是英国的精神。
So there's this poet that I discovered a couple of years ago. He's called Ross Gay, and he's written a book where he basically keeps track of the things that delight him. And that's things, that's people, that's moments, whatever.
我几年前发现了一位诗人。他叫Ross Gay，他写了一本书，基本上记录了让他快乐的事情。那是事情、人、时刻，什么都行。
And the word he used was "negligence." He said it's a negligence if people don't take the time to honor the things that they take delight in, but more importantly, that they share the things that they take delight in. And if you don't do that, there's a loss there. You have to do it to achieve humanity. You have to share delight.
他用的词是“疏忽”。他说，如果人们不花时间去尊重让他们快乐的事情，那就是一种疏忽，但更重要的是，如果不分享让他们快乐的事情。如果你不这样做，就会有损失。你必须这样做才能实现人性。你必须分享快乐。
And that's what we're going to be doing today, right?
这就是我们今天要做的，对吧？
Yes, that's exactly what we're going to be doing today. We're going to think about what delights us, why it delights us, why it's important to cultivate delight.
是的，这就是我们今天要做的。我们要思考什么让我们快乐，为什么它让我们快乐，为什么培养快乐很重要。
And with that, let me just hand over the show to you. You'll host the show from here. OK, you want to do the part where you say "from WBEZ Chicago?"
那么，就让我把节目交给你。你从这里开始主持。好的，你想做那个你说“来自WBEZ芝加哥”的部分吗？
I really do.
我真的想。
OK, hit it.
好的，开始吧。
Do I say, W-B-E-zed?
我是说，W-B-E-zed吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK. From W-B-E-zed Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi. Stay with us.
好的。来自W-B-E-zed芝加哥，这是《This American Life》。我是Bim Adewunmi。请继续收听。
Act One-- The Job of Delight.
第一幕——快乐的工作。
It's one thing to be attuned to delight, but it's quite another to scrape off a sample, stick it on a slide, and place it under a microscope. Enter Ross Gay, the poet I was talking about a moment ago. Ross is an English professor at Indiana University, and a couple of years ago, he embarked on a specific mission-- to think about delight. He made it a practice, in fact. For one calendar year, Ross would ask himself, what delights me? And then he would write it down.
调动快乐是一回事，但刮取样本、放在载玻片上并放在显微镜下观察则是另一回事。有请Ross Gay，我刚才提到的那位诗人。Ross是印第安纳大学的一名英语教授，几年前，他开始了一项特定的任务——思考快乐。事实上，他把它变成了一种练习。在日历年的一年里，Ross会问自己，什么让我快乐？然后他会写下来。
He set rules. He would do it every day, he would draft them quickly, and every single delight would be written by hand. He called them essayettes. Some of these essayettes eventually became a book-- The Book of Delights. Here's Ross reading an excerpt of Delight number 80 from the book, "Tomato Onboard," in his living room in Bloomington.
他制定了规则。他每天都会做，他会迅速起草，每一份快乐都是手写的。他称它们为随笔小品。其中一些随笔小品最终变成了一本书——《快乐之书》。这是Ross在他位于布卢明顿的客厅里读书中第80个快乐，“番茄在船上”的片段。
What you don't know until you carry a tomato seedling through the airport and onto a plane, is that carrying a tomato seedling through the airport and onto a plane will make people smile at you, almost like you're carrying a baby. I did not know this until today, carrying my little tomato, about three or four inches high in its four-inch plastic starter pot, which my friend Michael gave to me, smirking about how I was going to get it home.
当你带着番茄苗穿过机场并带上飞机之前，你不知道的是，带着番茄苗穿过机场并带上飞机，会让人对你微笑，几乎就像你带着婴儿一样。在今天之前我不知道这一点，带着我的小番茄，在大约三四英寸高的四英寸塑料启动盆里，这是我的朋友Michael给我的，他嘲笑着我打算怎么把它带回家。
Something about this at first felt naughty-- not comparing a tomato to a baby, but carrying the tomato under the plane. And so, I slid the thing into my bag while going through security, which made them pull the bag for inspection. When the security guy saw it was a tomato, he smiled and said, "I don't know how to check that. Have a good day."
起初，这感觉有点调皮——不是把番茄和婴儿相比，而是把番茄带到飞机上。所以我过安检时把它滑进了包里，这让他们拉开包进行检查。当安保人员看到它是番茄时，他微笑了，说：“我不知道怎么检查这个。祝你有个美好的一天。”
But I quickly realized one of its stems, which I almost wrote as arms, was broken from the jostling, and it only had four of them. So I decided I'd better just carry it out in the open. And the shower of love began. Before boarding the final leg of my flight, one of the workers said, "Nice tomato!" which I don't think was a come on.
但我很快意识到它的一个茎，我差点写成手臂，因为拥挤断了，它只有四个。所以我决定最好还是把它带在外面。爱之雨开始了。在登机飞行的最后一程前，一位工作人员说：“好番茄！”我不认为那是在勾搭。
And the flight attendant asked about the tomato at least five times-- not an exaggeration-- every time calling it "my tomato." "Where's my tomato? How's my tomato? You didn't lose my tomato, did you?" She even directed me to an open seat in the exit row. "Why don't you guys go sit there and stretch out?" I gathered my things and set the little guy in the window seat so she could look out.
空姐至少问了五次关于番茄的事——不是夸张——每次都称它为“我的番茄”。“我的番茄在哪里？我的番茄怎么样了？你没弄丢我的番茄，对吧？”她甚至指引我到出口排的一个空座位。“为什么你们不去那里坐下伸展一下？”我收拾好我的东西，把小家伙放在窗边的座位上，这样她就能向外看。
When I got my water, I poured some into the little guy's soil. When we got bumpy, I put my hand on the little guy's container, careful not to snap another arm off. And when we landed, and the pilot put the brakes on hard, my arm reflexively went across the seat, holding the little guy in place, the way my dad's arm would when he had to break in that car without belts to speak of, and one of my very favorite gestures in the encyclopedia of human gestures.
当我拿到水时，我倒了一些到小家伙的土壤里。当我们颠簸时，我把手放在小家伙的容器上，小心不要再折断另一条手臂。当我们降落，飞行员用力踩下刹车时，我的手臂反射性地横过座位，把小家伙固定在原位，就像我爸爸在那个几乎没有安全带的旧车里急刹车时会做的那样，这也是人类手势百科全书中我最喜欢的动作之一。
The Book of Delights is a series of daily snapshots into one man's habits and pleasures. If you ever wanted an essay about the specific sensation of applying coconut oil to a shower damp body, that would be delight number 101. Airports, and the people Ross encounters in them, come up a fair bit. His garden, where we spent a very delightful afternoon talking about bumblebees and potatoes, is the location of many a delight.
《快乐之书》是一系列关于一个男人习惯和快乐的日常快照。如果你曾经想要一篇关于在淋浴后潮湿的身体上涂抹椰子油这种特定感觉的文章，那就是第101个快乐。机场以及Ross在里面遇到的人，出现得相当多。他的花园，我们在那里度过了一个非常快乐的下午谈论大黄蜂和土豆，是许多快乐的发生地。
Some of the delights in the book were things that surprised him, while others were looking back in time, memories of people no longer here. A lot of them featured familiar faces in familiar places. Ross was getting to reassess his environment, and consider it through a new lens-- a delightful lens.
书中一些快乐是让他惊讶的事情，而另一些则是回首过去，对不再这里的人的记忆。很多快乐都以熟悉的地方熟悉的脸孔为特色。Ross得以重新评估他的环境，并透过一个新的镜头考虑它——一个快乐的镜头。
I was learning as I was going. And frankly, I was learning how much some of these things delighted me. The question is always, why does that delight me? What does it do to a person to study delight? Or, as it emerges, to study joy every single day for a year? What do you discover?
我在进行的过程中在学习。坦率地说，我在学习这些事情中有多少让我快乐。问题总是，为什么那让我快乐？研究快乐对一个人有什么影响？或者，正如它所呈现的那样，一年里每天研究喜悦？你发现了什么？
One of the things he discovered is the mechanics of how to find delight every day as a discipline. Because delight doesn't just arrive, you need to actively go looking for it.
他发现的事情之一是作为一种纪律如何每天找到快乐的机制。因为快乐不会自动到来，你需要主动去寻找它。
Being in a state of trying to train your curiosity, and trying to train this sense of not knowing. Delight and curiosity are really tied up. You have to be OK with not knowing things. You have to be actually invested and happy about not knowing things.
处于一种试图训练你的好奇心，并试图训练这种不知道的感觉的状态。快乐和好奇心真的紧密相连。你必须满足于不知道事情。你必须真正投入并对不知道事情感到快乐。
The Book of Delights is a peculiar thing, an undertaking of serious academic rigor that also makes you feel good. Those things aren't meant to go together. The book offers up many thoughts on what delight is or what it could be, but it never defines it explicitly. The takeaway is that delight, while important, is hard to pin down. Reading the book and talking to Ross about this made me feel like I was floating on a chemically-enhanced-- but perfectly legal in 11 states-- cloud.
《快乐之书》是一件奇特的事情，一项具有严肃学术严谨性的事业，但也让你感觉良好。那些事情本来是不应该放在一起的。这本书提出了许多关于什么是快乐或它可能是什么的想法，但它从未明确定义它。收获是，快乐虽然很重要，但很难被定义。读这本书并和Ross讨论这个问题让我感觉自己正漂浮在一种化学增强的——但在11个州完全合法——云端上。
I began to think of him as a sort of personal delight guru, and so my questions for him began to take on the strong whiff of a patchouli joss stick.
我开始把他看作是一种个人的快乐导师，所以对他的一连串问题开始带有强烈的广藿香香棒的气味。
Did you end up with a grand unifying theory on what delight is?
你最终得到了关于快乐是什么的宏大统一理论了吗？
[LAUGHS] No. No, but I did end up with what feels like a kind of beginning theory of what joy is. [LAUGHS] I just had an image. Delight is like the butterflies flying around and landing on the thing that is joy.
[笑] 没有。没有，但我最终得到了一个关于什么是喜悦的初步理论。[笑] 我刚才有个意象。快乐就像蝴蝶四处飞舞，降落在名为喜悦的东西上。
Right. See? Patchouli. To Ross, an important part of delight is that it's an invitation. By loving something, we allow other people an opportunity to love it too-- sharing, tapping someone on the shoulder to say, hey, look!
对。你看？广藿香。对Ross来说，快乐的重要部分是它是一个邀请。通过热爱某事物，我们让其他人也有机会去爱它——分享，拍拍某人的肩膀说，嘿，看！
So, often I feel like I've had the experience of walking through the world and not seeing anything. And then someone's like, did you see how that-- You don't see it until you see it. And then when you see it, you're like, whoa!
所以，我经常觉得我有过那种走过世界却什么都没看到的经历。然后有人说，你看到那个是怎么……你直到看到它才看到它。然后当你看到它时，你会想，哇！
We just had a bunch of people over here the other night, and this couple had this little kid. And so, he starts yelling, rainbow! Rainbow! [LAUGHS] And what did we do? We are all in here talking, being adults. Boom! We ran outside and started looking at the rainbow. Thank you. Thank you. It's like, come gasp with me. Come gasp with me. This is unbelievable.
我们前几天晚上刚有几个人过来，这对夫妇有个小孩子。所以，他开始大喊，彩虹！彩虹！[笑] 我们做了什么？我们都在这里谈话，作为成年人。砰！我们跑到外面开始看彩虹。谢谢。谢谢。这就像是，来和我一起惊叹。来和我一起惊叹。这真是不可思议。
Which brings us to Act Two-- The Squeals on the Bus. It's not surprising that it's a child that runs in to tell everyone to come look at a rainbow. There's a feeling that delight is the preserve of children, and any adult who finds delight easily might be a simpleton or a Pollyanna.
这就引出了第二幕——公交车上的尖叫。孩子跑进来告诉大家来看彩虹并不令人惊讶。人们有一种感觉，认为快乐是孩子的专利，任何轻易找到快乐的成年人可能都是傻瓜或盲目乐观的人。
Perhaps, you've noticed, this whole hour is an argument against that. But for Act 2, let's spend a little time with a five-year-old-- my colleague, Robyn Semien's son, Cole. He recently had an experience around a mundane thing most adults loathe-- commuting. He was going to ride the school bus for the very first time. Robyn has the story.
也许你注意到了，这一小时的内容就是对这种观点的反驳。但在第二幕中，让我们花点时间看看一个五岁的孩子——我的同事Robyn Semien的儿子，Cole。他最近围绕一件大多数成年人都厌恶的世俗琐事——通勤——有了体验。他将第一次乘坐校车。Robyn有这个故事。
Cole has been looking forward to this exact moment for years, more than kindergarten, or his first day at school. Taking the bus to Cole, is epic. So one morning this past September, with his new sneakers and Batman backpack on, Cole and I walked down our driveway.
Cole多年来一直期待着这一刻，比幼儿园或第一天上学还要期待。对Cole来说，坐公交车是史诗级的。所以九月的一个早上，穿着他的新运动鞋和蝙蝠侠背包，Cole和我走下车道。
I just can't wait! I'm a bus rider now!
我简直等不及了！我现在是个公交车乘客了！
What happened to old Cole?
旧的Cole怎么了？
Yeah, old Cole is dead now.
是的，旧的Cole现在死了。
Oh, wow!
哦，哇！
Yeah, when we get old, really old, we start to die.
是的，当我们老了，很老了，我们开始死去。
Well, these are very deep thoughts for the bus.
嗯，对于公交车来说这些是很深刻的想法。
Riding the bus, to Cole, was not about riding the bus. It meant he was gaining on his big sister Josie. She's 10, getting a hair closer to that mysterious, frustratingly out-of-reach thing that she has-- autonomy.
对Cole来说，坐公交车不是关于坐公交车。这意味着他正在追赶他的大姐姐Josie。她10岁，正一点点接近那个神秘、令人沮丧地遥不可及的东西——自主权。
No, let's wait for the bus here.
不，我们在这里等公交车。
We're going to walk down to the bus stop together. Come on.
我们要一起走到公交车站。来吧。
Why?
为什么？
Because that where the bus comes to get her, down on the corner. Did you know that?
因为那是公交车来接她的地方，在角落里。你知道吗？
No.
不知道。
For a kid obsessed with this trip, he's surprisingly vague on some of the details. See the tree?
对于一个痴迷于这次旅行的孩子来说，他对一些细节出奇地模糊。看到那棵树了吗？
What tree?
什么树？
That tree right down there on the corner.
角落里的那棵树。
Yeah.
是的。
That's our tree.
那是我们的树。
That's our tree?
那是我们的树？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Then we have to wait there?
那我们要在那儿等？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Is that how Josie does it every day?
Josie每天都那样做吗？
That's how she does it every single day. That's how she's been doing it for three years.
她每天都那样做。她已经这样做了三年了。
What?
什么？
I know! And now it's your turn.
我知道！现在轮到你了。
Yeah, and now it's not her turn.
是的，现在不轮到她了。
We get to the corner and wait. Hey, good morning. Our neighbor Ian pulls up, sees us, and gets out of his car.
我们到了角落等。嘿，早上好。我们的邻居Ian停下车，看到我们，从车里出来。
Guess what?
猜猜怎么着？
What's that?
什么事？
I'm waiting for my bus.
我在等我的公交车。
Oh! Your first day?
哦！你第一天？
Yeah, first time on the bus.
是的，第一次坐公交车。
All right!
太好了！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Thank you!
谢谢！
Cole beams. And pretty soon--
Cole满面春风。很快——
I think I hear a bus.
我想我听到公交车了。
You do?
你听到了？
Oh, it was just that car.
哦，那只是那辆车。
Cole wills the bus to come sooner, like everyone at every bus stop ever has done.
Cole祈求公交车快点来，就像每个公交车站的每个人都做过的一样。
I think I heard my bus. It sounded different. I think I heard it.
我想我听到我的公交车了。听起来不一样。我想我听到了。
I don't think so yet, bud.
我还觉得不是，伙计。
We practiced greeting the bus driver.
我们练习和公交车司机打招呼。
I'm going to say, hi, busdriver. I'm a little bit shy to say, how are you doing?
我要说，嗨，公交车司机。我有点害羞不敢说，你好吗？
We do this a couple more times till Cole tells me to stop because it's boring.
我们又做了几次，直到Cole叫我停止，因为这很无聊。
A little bit boring.
有点无聊。
And then more waiting. Cole's mood dips. He has doubts.
然后是更多的等待。Cole的情绪低落了。他有怀疑。
But what if there is not a spot for me in the bus?
但如果公交车上没有我的位子怎么办？
Oh, there'll be a spot for you. They know you're coming. We told them you're coming. OK?
哦，会有你的位子的。他们知道你要来。我们告诉他们你要来了。好吗？
OK. What's taking up that bus? It's taking too long for me. We've been here for over an hour.
好。那辆车在干什么？对我来说太慢了。我们在这儿已经超过一小时了。
It's been 10 minutes.
才10分钟。
And it's taking too long. It's taking crappy long!
而且这太慢了。太烂了，太慢了！
Crappy long?
烂得慢？
Yes.
是的。
That's not something that you say?
那不是你该说的话？
[LAUGHS] Crappy!
[笑] 烂！
No, no. We don't say that.
不，不。我们不那样说。
Fine.
好吧。
I'm a little worried that maybe Cole has overimagined the bus ride, and it won't live up. That years of anticipation will only disappoint him in the end. And then rounding the corner--
我有点担心Cole可能对公交车旅行的想象力太过了，它可能无法达到预期。多年的期待最终只会让他失望。然后绕过拐角——
[GASPS]
[喘息声]
Oh, man!
天哪！
That's my bus! It's really happening!
那是我的公交车！这真的发生了！
[LAUGHS] Stand to the side. OK, let's go. Let's go.
[笑] 站到一边。好的，我们走吧。我们走吧。
Cole tears past me and up the bus steps like it's nothing. He's daring, I think to myself.
Cole从我身边冲过去，跑上公交车的台阶，好像没什么大不了的。他在冒险，我对自己想。
Love you, bye!
爱你，再见！
Bye, mom!
再见，妈妈！
Love you! Good morning.
爱你！早上好。
Cole stood for a second longer, facing the rows of seats and kids, taking it all in, completely lit up.
Cole站了一会儿，面对着排排的座位和孩子们，吸收着这一切，整个人都被点亮了。
I can't believe it! I'm on the bus! Yes! Yes! It's my first time.
我不敢相信！我在公交车上！耶！耶！这是我第一次。
He's fine. Better than fine.
他没事。比没事还要好。
Now this is what I'm talking about.
现在这就是我在说的。
That was New Cole, with his producer, Robyn Semien.
那是新Cole，和他的制作人Robyn Semien。
Act Three-- Mrs. Meek shall inherit the Earth. I think delight might actually be more profound when you've experienced more, including real loss and tragedy. Ross Gay's book of delights is edged in despair. In it, Ross writes about his dearly departed friends, his uncle Earl, his father. He calls them his deceased beloveds. But that's the way of delight.
第三幕——温顺的人将继承地球。我认为当你经历了更多的事情，包括真正的损失和悲剧时，快乐可能真的会更深刻。Ross Gay的快乐之书带有绝望的边缘。在书中，Ross写到了他亲爱的已故朋友，他的伯父Earl，他的父亲。他称他们为他已故的挚爱。但这就是快乐的方式。
When I think of joy, grown up joy is made up of our sorrow, just like it's made up of what is pleasing to us. Often, it felt like I wasn't going to be able to talk about delight without talking about these other things. Delight often implies its absence.
当我想到喜悦时，成熟的喜悦是由我们的悲伤组成的，就像它是由让我们愉悦的事情组成的一样。通常，我觉得如果我不谈论这些其他事情，我就无法谈论快乐。快乐通常意味着它的缺失。
Noriko Meek knows all about that. After 72 years on Earth, she's made some changes lately. Her daughter, Miki, talked to her about it.
Noriko Meek非常了解这一点。在地球上度过了72年后，她最近做了一些改变。她的女儿Miki和她谈了这件事。
My mom is 72 years old, and in this new phase of her life, where she's all about doing whatever she wants. I'm glad for her, but sometimes it's kind of annoying. Recently, I was her chauffeur on a road trip through Texas and New Mexico. She woke me up at 5:30 in the morning so we could drive an hour to watch the sunrise from some sand dunes in the middle of nowhere.
我妈妈72岁了，在她人生的这个新阶段，她热衷于做任何她想做的事。我为她感到高兴，但有时这有点烦人。最近，我在德克萨斯州和新墨西哥州的公路旅行中做了她的司机。她在早上5:30叫醒我，这样我们就能开车一小时去看荒郊野外沙丘上的日出。
She insisted on hanging out in a cold crappy parking lot to take pictures of a rainbow. Then when I asked if I could interview her, she told me, "maybe." But first, she needed to take a bath. Her second one for the day.
她坚持要在寒冷破旧的停车场逗留，去拍彩虹的照片。然后当我问是否可以采访她时，她告诉我，“也许吧”。但首先，她需要洗个澡。她今天第二次洗澡。
Oh!
哦！
When she finally got out, she sat next to me on the queen bed we were sharing-- one, two, three-- and then pulled out some floss.
当她终于出来时，她坐在我们共用的那张大床边——一，二，三——然后掏出一些牙线。
I should clean my teeth.
我应该清洁我的牙齿。
You're going to clean your teeth while we're talking?
我们在说话的时候你要清洁牙齿？
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So gross.
太恶心了。
No worry! I can do whatever.
没关系！我可以做任何事。
Except that I'm sleeping right next to you.
除非我就睡在你旁边。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I felt that.
我感觉到了。
The first time I notice she'd changed was over the summer, standing outside of my brother's house. We'd been talking about where to go grocery shopping, when she suddenly switched subjects. She asked me, with this smiling but also totally serious face, if I could tell that she was glowing.
我第一次注意到她变了是在夏天，站在我哥哥家外面。我们一直在讨论去哪里买杂货，她突然转换了话题。她问我，带着微笑但又完全严肃的脸，我是否能看出她在发光。
I wasn't totally sure what she was talking about, so I told her, um, yeah, I guess you look nice. And then I just as quickly changed the subject back to the cheap produce section at Trader Joe's.
我不确定她在说什么，所以我告诉她，嗯，是的，我想你看起来不错。然后我同样迅速地把话题转回了Trader Joe's便宜的农产品区。
So why did you ask me that then?
那你那时候为什么要问我？
Well, because to me it was so obvious you've probably seen it. Because inside, I mean, I think I was glowing inside, just radiating joy. Just delight, you know?
嗯，因为对我来说太明显了，你可能已经看到了。因为内心，我是说，我想我的内心在发光，只是放射出喜悦。只是快乐，你知道吗？
I don't think I've ever used the word "delight" in a conversation with you ever.
我不认为我在和你谈话时用过“快乐”这个词。
I don't think I start using this word-- yeah, just recently, I think. Because I tell my friends, my life is just delightful, you know?
我不认为我开始用这个词——是的，只是最近，我想。因为我告诉我的朋友，我的生活简直是快乐，你知道吗？
You say that?
你这么说？
Yeah, I do.
是的，我这么说。
I've never heard you say that.
我从未听过你这么说。
To my friends.
对我的朋友。
This is not the mom I grew up with. She was practical, frugal, and not a big fan of hugs, kisses, or elaborating on her feelings. My mom was married to my dad for 43 years. They met in college in their early 20s, and then went on to have six kids. My mom stayed at home with us full-time, and she was kind of a hard-ass. OK, so what does the word "delight" mean to you? How would you even define that?
这和我成长的那个妈妈不一样。她务实、节俭，不喜欢拥抱、亲吻或阐述自己的感受。我妈妈和我爸爸结婚43年了。他们在20多岁上大学时认识，然后生了六个孩子。我妈妈全职在家带我们，她有点强硬。好的，那么“快乐”这个词对你意味着什么？你怎么定义它？
Delight is just like light your heart out, like ignite something, you know? At the moment, you just feel lightness.
快乐就像点燃你的心，就像点燃某种东西，你知道吗？在那一刻，你只是感到轻松。
So if you were to list what delights you, what's on that list?
所以如果你要列出什么让你快乐，清单上有什么？
OK, go first thing in the morning I wake up, and I go to the bathroom, and my Toto toilet is warm.
好的，早上我醒来的第一件事，我去洗手间，我的Toto马桶是暖和的。
We have a Japanese toilet with a warm toilet seat.
我们有一个带暖和马桶圈的日本马桶。
Yeah, and I just sit on it. It's just so warm. And I just feel I am so happy. I really feel it. I am so happy! And it happens every morning.
是的，我就坐在上面。它太暖和了。我就觉得自己太快乐了。我真的感觉到了。我太快乐了！而且它每天早上都会发生。
[LAUGHS] Yeah, it's a consistent delight.
[笑] 是的，这是一个持续的快乐。
Mm-hmm. Consistent Delight.
嗯哼。持续的快乐。
Other things on her list of delights? Eating discounted donuts for breakfast-- she keeps her freezer stocked with them-- going to a ballet class for seniors, and reading biographies in bed for two hours every night. She also started traveling for fun for the very first time in her life. Right now, she's on a big nature streak. She's hiked through Joshua Tree, the Badlands, Death Valley, the Pyrenees, and on, and on, and on. She exhausts me.
她快乐清单上的其他东西？早餐吃打折的甜甜圈——她冰箱里常备着它们——参加老年人的芭蕾舞课，每晚在床上看两个小时的传记。她也开始有生以来第一次为了乐趣去旅行。现在，她正在经历一段大自然的狂潮。她徒步走过了约书亚树、荒地、死亡谷、比利牛斯山脉，等等，等等。她让我精疲力竭。
So have you ever felt this way before?
所以你以前有过这种感觉吗？
No.
没有。
Never?
从没？
Never.
从没。
Not even when we were kids or when you had us?
甚至在我们是孩子或者你生我们的时候？
No.
没有。
[LAUGHS] You said no!
[笑] 你说没有！
Yeah, I don't think I felt delighted.
是的，我不认为我感到快乐。
[LAUGHS] What did you feel?
[笑] 你感觉到了什么？
I was glad you guys are born and safe, but I don't think-- raising kids, taking care of your dad-- yeah, I don't think I ever used the word "delight." Because I mean, I placed myself always like my needs, or whatever, last. Money, or whatever, time. But then after kids all gone, and your dad's gone, finally I have my life, and I can do what I want, whenever, whatever. Just no stress. No responsibility.
我很高兴你们出生并安全，但我不认为——养育孩子，照顾你爸爸——是的，我不认为我用过“快乐”这个词。因为我是说，我总是把我的需求，或者其他什么，放在最后。钱，或者其他，时间。但后来孩子们都走了，你爸爸也走了，终于我有了自己的生活，我可以做我想做的事，随时，任何事。没有压力。没有责任。
That's why I say light, I feel so light. And I think delight-- delightful is just the exact adjective for my life at this point.
这就是为什么我说轻，我感觉太轻了。而且我认为快乐——愉快简直是我生活在这个阶段的准确形容词。
My life is really amazing. And then I see movies. Three movies a week sometimes, at 8:30 in the morning, and that's just wonderful.
我的生活真的太棒了。然后我看电影。有时一周三部电影，在早上8:30，那简直太棒了。
How many other people in the movie theater?
电影院里还有多少人？
Nobody. Just me. Just great.
没人。只有我。太棒了。
After my dad died four years ago from cancer, my mom completely fell apart in a way I'd never seen her before. She suddenly became needy, she openly cried. Before then, all her energy had gone into keeping my dad alive. She'd spent a decade caring for him, constantly driving him to the ER in the middle of the night, and checking his oxygen levels while he slept.
四年前我爸爸因癌症去世后，我妈妈完全崩溃了，以一种我从未见过的方式。她突然变得依赖，她公开哭泣。在那之前，她所有的精力都投入到维持我爸爸的生命上。她花了十年时间照顾他，半夜不断开车送他去急诊室，在睡梦中检查他的氧气水平。
We never really talked about what it was like for her watching him deteriorate so much that sometimes he felt like a stranger. But then, when he was suddenly gone, all the feelings she'd pushed down came out in this big devastating wave. For a while, she could barely function.
我们从未真正谈论过看着他恶化到有时让他感觉像个陌生人的那种感觉对她来说是什么样的。但后来，当他突然离开时，她压抑的所有感受都以这种巨大的破坏性浪潮爆发出来。有一段时间，她几乎无法生活。
Four years. It took four years. I really took a very small step forward after your dad died, just to make sure I'm alive. So each morning I get up and I have this terrible pain in my chest. But then I just say, OK, I think I can make myself live to the end of this day. And that's all I thought about.
四年。花了四年。我确实在你爸爸去世后迈出了非常小的一步，只是为了确保我还活着。所以我每天早上起床，我的胸口有这种剧痛。但我只是说，好的，我想我可以让自己活到这一天结束。这就是我所想的全部。
Do you feel surprised sometimes that you feel this good?
你有时对你感觉这么好感到惊讶吗？
I mean, when dad died and I was just so sad, I didn't think this would ever happen.
我是说，当我爸爸去世而我感到那么难过时，我没想过这会发生。
Hmm.
嗯。
I really thought my life was over.
我真的以为我的生活结束了。
My mom grieved intensely like this for about six months, and then I asked her to come live with me in my tiny apartment for a while. She said yes, and I didn't expect her to. I thought she'd worry too much about being a burden. But this time, she agreed with me that staying with me might actually make her feel better. I wouldn't let her sleep on the couch, so we got into this whole nighttime routine where we'd put on our pajamas and read in my bed, like some old married couple.
我妈妈像这样剧烈地悲伤了大约六个月，然后我让她搬到我的小公寓住一段时间。她说好，我没想到她会同意。我以为她会太担心成为负担。但这次，她同意了我的看法，住在我这里可能真的会让她感觉好些。我没让她睡在沙发上，所以我们养成了这种整个夜间的惯例，我们会穿上睡衣在我的床上读书，就像一对老夫妻。
My brother came to visit us once. At 10:00 PM, my mom tapped me on the knee and said, time to hit the hay, Mik. We sat up together, and he was like, what is happening? My mom's choice to stay with me marked the beginning of her opening herself up and putting herself first. Right now, her travel calendar for 2020 is already all booked up-- Alabama, Alaska, Italy, Japan, Chicago, and Spain.
我哥哥有次来看我们。晚上10点，我妈妈拍拍我的膝盖说，该睡觉了，Mik。我们一起坐起来，他就像，发生了什么？我妈妈选择住在我这里，标志着她开始敞开心扉并将自己放在第一位。现在，她2020年的旅行计划已经全部排满了——阿拉巴马州、阿拉斯加、意大利、日本、西班牙和芝加哥。
Maybe because my life is getting shorter, that pushes me to be more courageous.
也许因为我的生命越来越短，这推动我变得更有勇气。
Yeah.
是的。
So every day I wake up with some expectation, anticipation. Yeah, on my calendar, there's nothing I don't want to do.
所以我每天醒来都带有一些期望，期待。是的，在我的日历上，没有我不想要做的事。
If dad had stayed alive and been healthy, do you think you could still feel the way that you do now?
如果爸爸还活着而且健康，你认为你还能像现在这样感觉吗？
Probably not. Isn't that terrible? Because with him, my life, I'll have more responsibilities. He will be number one in my life. And then, my needs will come after his. Yeah, so it's just almost sometimes sounds like, oh, I'm glad he's gone. I'm not saying that. But because he's gone, this is the life I have, and I just want it to be delightful, you know? I think it's OK.
大概不会。那不是太可怕了吗？因为有他，我的生活，我会有更多的责任。他会是我生命中的第一位。然后，我的需求会在他之后。是的，所以它有时听起来简直像，哦，我很高兴他走了。我不是那个意思。但因为他走了，这是我拥有的生活，我只是想要它变得快乐，你知道吗？我想没关系。
It is OK.
没关系。
Yeah. These questions kind of dumb.
是的。这些问题有点笨。
That's my mom telling me she thinks my questions are kind of dumb. [LAUGHS] Why is it dumb?
那是我妈妈告诉我她认为我的问题有点笨。[笑] 为什么它笨？
Delightful? Just too annoying.
快乐？太烦人了。
People will think you're really annoying?
人们会认为你真的很烦人？
Yeah, I think so. That's why I don't know why you want to do this, because the people like, oh, my gosh! I'm so sick of listening to her. So self-absorbed, you know?
是的，我想是这样。这就是为什么我不知道你为什么想这样做，因为人们就像，哦，天哪！我听她说话听腻了。太自我沉浸了，你知道吗？
And so, what would you say to that?
那么，你会对那个说什么？
I'm sorry. I do feel that way genuinely. And sometimes I feel like I earned it.
我很抱歉。我确实真诚地那样感觉。有时我觉得我赢得了它。
Miki Meek, a constant delight. Also a producer on our show. Coming up, would you call yourself a dealer of delight?
Miki Meek，持续的快乐。也是我们节目的制作人。接下来，你会称自己为快乐的经销商吗？
Hmm? You the Feds? I'mma deal with now? I know it was a setup!
嗯？你是联邦调查局的？我现在要交易？我知道这是个陷阱！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I knew it! Yes. I'm full of delight, I'm slanging delight. You know what I'm saying? I'm on the internet corners. What you need? What you need? I got it!
我知道！是的。我充满快乐，我正在兜售快乐。你知道我在说什么吗？我在互联网的角落里。你需要什么？你需要什么？我有！
That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
那是一分钟后来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi taking over the show from Ira for the day. Yes, we are coming over here stealing your jobs. Today's show-- The Show of Delights. Stories about how we go about making, and feeling, and actively seeking out delight, which is all around us, by the way. The poet Ross Gay, ambassador for delight, writes about a time he was in New York, and saw a man feeding a pigeon perched on his shoulder. He looks closer, and sees--
这是《This American Life》。我是Bim Adewunmi，今天从Ira那里接管节目。是的，我们来这里偷你们的工作了。今天的节目——快乐的节目。关于我们如何制作、感受并积极寻求快乐的故事，顺便说一句，快乐无处不在。诗人Ross Gay，快乐的大使，写到了他在纽约时的一次经历，看到一个男人喂食停在他肩膀上的鸽子。他凑近一看，看到——
-- the bird dipping its head into the hand the man must have been holding very near to his own face, so that the feeding was not only kind of romantic, but alluded to that original feeding the bird experienced-- a mother dropping masticated vittles into the tiny chippers gaped mouth, which is, after all, the first romance.
——这只鸟把头伸进那个人可能一直举在他脸附近的那个手里，所以喂食不仅有点浪漫，而且还暗指那只鸟经历的最初的喂食——母亲将咀嚼过的食物掉进微小雏鸟张开的嘴里，那毕竟是最初的浪漫。
It sounds like something out of a children's picture book, doesn't it? Feeding, caring, being companions to our animals. And with that, we've arrived at Act Four-- The Elephant in the Bedroom. Disa Skaff has a job that's out of a children's book. She's a night zookeeper at the Denver Zoo. So while most people are asleep, she's doling out snacks, checking the animals are warm and cozy, turning out their lights, and saying goodnight. Dana Chivvis recently spent a night with Disa at the zoo.
这听起来像是儿童绘本里的东西，不是吗？喂养、照顾、做我们动物的伙伴。随着这一点，我们到达了第四幕——卧室里的大象。Disa Skaff有一份出自儿童书的工作。她是丹佛动物园的一名夜间动物管理员。所以当大多数人睡觉时，她正在分发零食，检查动物们是否温暖舒适，熄灯，道晚安。Dana Chivvis最近在动物园和Disa度过了一晚。
Being at the zoo at night is like being backstage hours after a play has ended. The public is long gone. The vendors have packed up their Dippin' Dots and zoo swag. The paths that wind around the animal exhibits are empty and dark, and a little creepy. I follow Disa's flashlight as we walk around. Disa, your job is very dark.
在夜间的动物园就像在一场戏结束后几个小时站在后台。公众早就走了。摊贩们已经打包了他们的Dippin' Dots和动物园纪念品。环绕动物展区的道路又空又黑，还有点令人毛骨悚然。我跟随Disa的手电筒走动。Disa，你的工作非常黑暗。
Yeah, but you can see where you're walking.
是的，但你能看到你走在哪里。
Usually, it's just her, the security guards, another night zookeeper, and 3,000 wild animals. Disa has the best job in the whole world.
通常，只有她、保安、另一名夜间动物管理员和3000只野生动物。Disa拥有世界上最好的工作。
It's the best job in the whole world.
这是世界上最好的工作。
See? We walk into a building through a back door-- the special zookeeper entrance. Disa turns the lights on, and I see something I've never seen before-- an elephant on the ground, on his side, (WHISPERS) sleeping. Describe it.
看吧？我们穿过后门进入一栋建筑——特殊的动物管理员入口。Disa打开灯，我看到了我从未见过的事情——一只大象在地上，侧着身子，（耳语）睡觉。描述一下。
So Chuck is sleeping. Oh, he's waking up. He just stretched his back leg out. He's got to push up with his front feet, doing some Upward Facing Dog stretch. And now he's ready for some food.
所以Chuck在睡觉。哦，他醒了。他刚才把后腿伸开了。他必须用前脚支撑起来，做一些向上狗式的伸展运动。现在他准备好吃饭了。
Each of the 450 different species at the zoo has its own nighttime routine, and Disa's put them to bed so many times by now, she knows their individual sleep preferences. Where they like to sleep, how they like to sleep, with whom they like to sleep. There's a lady lizard who uses a male lizard as a mattress, and lemurs who cuddle in branches. The gorillas are the touchiest about their sleep. Disa avoids them after 5:00. Do any animals spoon?
动物园里的450种不同物种都有自己的夜间惯例，Disa已经哄它们上床睡觉很多次了，以至于她知道它们各自的睡眠偏好。它们喜欢在哪里睡，喜欢怎么睡，喜欢和谁一起睡。有一只女蜥蜴用男蜥蜴做床垫，还有依偎在树枝里的狐猴。大猩猩对睡眠最敏感。Disa在5点之后会避开它们。有什么动物会依偎吗？
Oh, a lot of animals spoon. Our Red River hogs spoon.
哦，很多动物会依偎。我们的红河猪会依偎。
The Red River hogs?
红河猪？
Yeah, we'll see them. They sleep like a pack of sausages.
是的，我们会看到的。它们睡得像一包香肠。
Sorry, hogs. I'm sure she means chicken sausages. There are one-year-old Komodo dragon siblings who sleep crammed together inside a log. A quick aside, because I find it delightful-- those little Komodo guys don't have a father, because their mother impregnated herself. I'm not kidding. Female Komodo dragons can impregnate themselves. Disa knows all the animals, many on a first-name basis. She checks on Daphne the crocodile, and Coco the porcupine, Murray the moray, and fern the bongo.
抱歉，猪。我肯定她指的是鸡肉香肠。有一岁大的科莫多巨蜥兄妹挤在一根原木里睡觉。顺便说一句，因为我觉得它很让人快乐——那些小科莫多巨蜥没有父亲，因为它们的母亲让自己怀孕了。我不开玩笑。雌性科莫多巨蜥可以让自己怀孕。Disa认识所有的动物，很多都是直呼其名。她检查了鳄鱼Daphne，豪猪Coco，海鳗Murray，还有非洲羚羊Fern。
Fern? Hey, fern?
Fern？嘿，Fern？
[SNUFFLING]
[嗅探声]
Fern's trying to eat my microphone.
Fern正在试图吃我的麦克风。
She wants a treat. We're just saying night-night.
她想要个零食。我们只是说晚安。
These animals know Disa. They have relationship. They're not alarmed to see us. In fact, a lot of them seem expectant, like they've been waiting for her to come by and tuck them in. In the kangaroo section, everyone is crouching in a group.
这些动物认识Disa。它们有关系。看到我们它们并不惊慌。事实上，它们中的很多看起来充满期待，就像它们一直等着她过来给它们盖好被子。在袋鼠区，每个人都蹲在一群里。
Goodnight, roos!
晚安，袋鼠！
Bakari the zebra is still standing up. Zebras can rest on their feet.
斑马Bakari仍然站着。斑马可以在脚上休息。
Good night, sir.
晚安，先生。
Bugsy and Boo otter literally cannot wait one more second for their dinner.
水獭Bugsy和Boo简直一秒钟都不能再等它们的晚餐了。
[ANIMAL SOUNDS]
[动物声音]
I was going to play you a bunch more cute animal sounds here, but my editor said move it along. So here's some music instead.
我本来想在这里给你播放更多可爱的动物声音，但我编辑说继续吧。所以这里有一些音乐作为代替。
What's so charming about animals going to sleep? Is it that we're seeing creatures that are so different from us doing something so familiar, reminding us of a commonality that we all have to do this one thing to survive? You know what? Who cares? Here's a baby flamingo who wants us to leave him alone so he can get some shut eye.
动物入睡有什么迷人的地方？是因为我们看到了和我们如此不同的生物做着如此熟悉的事情，提醒我们每个人为了生存都必须做这一件事的共性吗？你知道吗？谁在乎呢？这是一只小火烈鸟，想要我们离开他让他闭目养神。
[SQUAWKING INDIGNANTLY]
[愤怒地嘎嘎叫]
Sorry! Disa has the easygoing and gentle demeanor of someone who legitimately loves her job, a job we all said we wanted as kids, along with firefighter and astronaut. And unlike the rest of us civilians at the zoo, she gets to have direct contact with the animals, take care of them, which she loves. When I'm there, the zookeepers are hand-feeding Eleanor, a four-month-old kudu, which is a kind of antelope.
抱歉！Disa拥有一个真正热爱她的工作的人那种随和温柔的风度，那是我们所有人小时候说我们想要的工作，连同消防员和宇航员一起。而且不像动物园里我们其余的平民，她能与动物直接接触，照顾它们，这让她热爱。当我在那里时，动物管理员正在手工喂Eleanor，一只四个月大的库杜，那是一种羚羊。
Eleanor stands on spindly legs and chugs the entire bottle in one go.
Eleanor站在细长的腿上，一次就把整瓶喝光了。
[CHUGGING]
[咕噜咕噜]
Good girl, Eleanor.
好女孩，Eleanor。
Eleanor's dad, Joe, comes over, looking for some treats, which Disa gives him.
Eleanor的爸爸Joe过来了，寻找一些零食，Disa给了他。
This is Joe, the dad.
这是Joe，爸爸。
And then she does something else. Did you just eat one of Joe's treats?
然后她做了另一件事。你刚才吃了Joe的一个零食吗？
I did.
我吃了。
How was it?
怎么样？
Not at tasty as I thought they'd be. I just ate a little. Like, that bit.
没我想象的那么好吃。我只是吃了一点。就像，那一点。
I take a bite. It's kind of grassy. Disa says primate biscuits aren't bad. Then we both confess to trying dog food when we were kids. There is one animal who's having a rough go of it. We walk around to the back of the great ape house, and Disa points her flashlight at a tree. At the top, tangled up in some branches, is a sheet blowing gently in the wind.
我吃了一口。有点像草。Disa说灵长类饼干不坏。然后我们都承认小时候试过狗粮。有一个动物的情况有点糟。我们走到巨猿馆的后面，Disa用手电筒指着一棵树。在树顶，缠绕在一些树枝里的是一张在风中轻轻飘动的床单。
One of the reasons we came down here is we have Jaya the orangutan.
我们来到这里的原因之一是我们有红毛猩猩Jaya。
Oh, my gosh!
哦，天哪！
He is newer to the zoo.
他是动物园的新成员。
Is that--
那是——
So he is currently sleeping in a tree.
所以他现在睡在树上。
Wait, that's-- no.
等等，那是——不。
Yeah.
是的。
That's an orang--
那是红毛——
Yeah.
是的。
Wait, is he wearing a blanket?
等等，他盖着毯子吗？
Yeah. He's wrapped in a sheet.
是的。他裹在床单里。
Jaya should be inside, where it's warm. Orangutans are from the rainforest of Sumatra and Borneo. And I sound this baffled because I really thought I was just looking at a wayward sheet caught in a tree. But then the sheet moved. Jaya was under it, clutching it tightly around his little body.
Jaya应该在里面，那里很暖和。红毛猩猩来自苏门答腊和婆罗洲的雨林。我听起来如此困惑是因为我真的以为我只是在看一张挂在树上的床单。但随后床单动了。Jaya在下面，紧紧地把它裹在小小的身体周围。
It really looks like there's a little person up there.
看起来真像上面有个小人儿。
Yeah.
是的。
Jaya has only been at the zoo for a few months. He moved here from a zoo in Minnesota in August. He's still getting used to it. A few days ago something spooked him. He retreated to the yard and climbed up a tree.
Jaya在动物园只有几个月。他八月份从明尼苏达州的一个动物园搬到这里。他还在适应。几天前有什么东西吓到了他。他撤退到院子里，爬上了树。
Do you worry about him in the cold like this?
你担心他这样在寒冷里吗？
We do worry about him, yeah. So from the records today, it looks like the keeper took some binoculars and tried to look at his fingers and toes, to see if there are any signs of frostbite, and they're really bright red. So we'll just check on him throughout the night.
我们确实担心他，是的。所以从今天的记录看，看起来饲养员用双筒望远镜试着看他的手指和脚趾，看是否有任何冻伤的迹象，它们真的非常红。所以我们整晚都会查看他。
I guess one of the complicated things about delight is that it can exist, like a kernel, at the center of misfortune. Sometimes delight is found in the ability to take care of another living thing that needs you. It's nice to be needed.
我想关于快乐的复杂事情之一是它作为一种内核，可以存在于不幸的中心。有时快乐是在能够照顾需要你的另一个生命的能力中找到的。被需要真好。
Do you have a favorite animal?
你有什么喜欢的动物吗？
My favorite animal is Rudy the rhino.
我最喜欢的动物是犀牛Rudy。
Why?
为什么？
Because he's the best.
因为他是最好的。
Why, is he the best?
为什么，他是最好的吗？
He's like a puppy.
他像只小狗。
Yeah?
是吗？
So he's really gentle and nice. Mostly, I think I love Rudy because most of the animals that I have built a relationship with because I see them all the time. It's usually because I give them food. Rudy, I do not give him food, but he will come to me when I call him. If he's outside and I need him to come inside because it's too cold, I call him, and he'll come over. Yeah, he responds to me, and I don't know, he's my best friend. [LAUGHS]
所以他真的很温柔很好。大多数情况下，我想我爱Rudy是因为大多数我建立关系的动物是因为我一直看到它们。通常是因为我给它们食物。Rudy，我没有给过他食物，但我叫他时他会来到我身边。如果他在外面，我需要他进来，因为太冷了，我叫他，他会过来。是的，他回应我，我不知道，他是我的最好朋友。[笑]
This thing about Rudy and what a nice guy he is, what if the joy we get from interacting with animals, the idea that we can have relationships of mutual affection, is a total illusion? What if the truth is that, for these animals anyway, our relationships are mostly transactional? Does the delight then disappear? Or maybe that is the transaction? We give them food and they give us delight.
关于Rudy以及他是个好人的这件事，如果从与动物互动中获得的喜悦，即我们能有相互情感关系的想法，是一个完全的错觉呢？如果事实是，无论如何对这些动物来说，我们的关系主要是交易性的呢？那快乐就消失了吗？或者也许那就是交易？我们给它们食物，它们给我们快乐。
Just got a text message.
刚收到一条短信。
There's one last moment I want to tell you about.
还有最后一刻我想告诉你。
So one of our hoof stock keepers, Matt, is asking if we can check on Charlie's guillotine door to make sure it got closed. He's sure he did it, but you know how it is. He'll wake up at 2:00 AM in a panic.
所以我们的一位蹄类动物饲养员Matt问我们能否检查Charlie的断头台门以确保它被关上了。他肯定他做了，但你知道是怎么回事。他会在凌晨2:00恐慌地醒来。
Charlie is a Vietnamese pot-bellied pig. His day-keeper, Matt, couldn't remember if he'd shut the door to his yard. We go to check on Charlie, and, yes, his door is closed. He's completely sacked out. He's made himself a big nest of hay, somehow managed to cover most of his body with it, his head included. So all we can see is his belly rising and falling with each deep, sleepy breath.
Charlie是一只越南大肚猪。他的日间饲养员Matt不记得是否关上了他院子的门。我们去检查Charlie，是的，他的门关着。他完全昏睡过去了。他为自己做了一个大干草窝，不知怎么设法用它覆盖了身体的大部分，包括他的头。所以我们只能看到他的肚子随着每一次深沉、困倦的呼吸起伏。
'Night Charlie! Good boy!
晚安Charlie！乖孩子！
I like Charlie. He's terse, but uncomplicated, you know? He knows his name. He recognizes that Disa is talking to him and he responds. They're communicating across species. For me, this one short interaction contains all the magic of her job. Disa and a pig are talking to each other.
我喜欢Charlie。他话不多，但并不复杂，你知道吗？他知道他的名字。他认出Disa在对他说话，他会回应。它们在跨物种沟通。对我来说，这次简短的互动包含了她工作的所有魔力。Disa和一头猪在互相说话。
Dana Chivvis, whose love for her dog delights me, co-produced today's show. And for those of you who care, Jaya the orangutan is back indoors, frostbite free.
Dana Chivvis，她对她狗的热爱让我快乐，也是今天节目的联合制作人。对于那些关心的人，红毛猩猩Jaya已经回到室内，没有冻伤。
Act Five-- Delight At the End of the Tunnel.
第五幕——隧道尽头的快乐。
I suspect that it's simply a feature of being an adult, what I will call being grown, or a grown person--
我怀疑这只是身为成年人的一个特征，我称之为“成熟”，或一个成熟的人——
Again, Ross Gay.
再次，Ross Gay。
-- to have endured some variety of thorough emotional turmoil, to have made your way to the brink, and if you're lucky, to have stepped back from it, if not permanently, then for some time, or time to time.
——承受了各种彻底的情绪动荡，走到了边缘，如果你幸运的话，退回了它，如果不是永久，那么至少有一段时间，或者时有时无。
This is delight number 100-- "Grown." Ross goes on to talk about the importance of seeing things as they are, in the moment where you don't feel panic, or despair, or doom.
这是第100个快乐——“成熟”。Ross继续谈论看到事物本来面目的重要性，在你不感到恐慌、绝望或厄运的那一刻。
And knowing what I have felt before, and might feel again, feel a sense of relief, which is cousin to, or rather, water to delight.
并且知道我以前感受过什么，可能还会再感受到，感受到一种解脱，它与快乐是亲戚，或者说是快乐的水。
This last story is about someone who's defined by delight, but then loses it. I first got to know her through her blog, Little Known Black History Facts, which is one of my favorite things.
这最后一个故事关于一个由快乐定义，但后来失去了它的人。我第一次通过她的博客“鲜为人知的黑人历史事实”认识她，那是我最喜欢的东西之一。
It's an affectionate parody of the Black History Month rollout of African-American excellence that happens every February. But the achievements on this site, they're all made up. Things like, inventor of the church clap, or first person to put more than 25 barrettes in one child's hair at one time. You know, black people stuff.
那是对每年二月举行的非裔美国人卓越表现的黑人历史月推出的深情模仿。但这个网站上的成就，全是编出来的。像，教会掌声的发明者，或者第一个在孩子头发里一次戴上超过25个发夹的人。你知道，黑人的东西。
The person behind these perfectly observed jokes is one of the funniest people I know. Her name is Tracy Clayton, although, you may know her as Brokey McPoverty on the internet, where she has legions of fans. Tracy ran Little Known Black History Facts for five years. She's the creator of so many of my favorite things, but Little Known Black History Facts is the one I think about most often, even if Tracy doesn't.
这些被完美观察到的笑话背后的人是我认识的最有趣的人之一。她的名字叫Tracy Clayton，虽然，你可能在互联网上认识她为Brokey McPoverty，在那里她有大批粉丝。Tracy经营了“鲜为人知的黑人历史事实”五年。她是这么多我最喜欢东西的创造者，但“鲜为人知的黑人历史事实”是我最常想起的，即使Tracy不这么想。
Do you remember anything from that ridiculous blog?
你还记得那个荒谬博客里的任何东西吗？
No.
不。
There was Derek Morris, who was the first person to rap loudly to himself while standing at a bus stop.
有Derek Morris，他是第一个在车站站着时对自己大声说唱的人。
Don't like him.
不喜欢他。
No.
不。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There was Haverford Bliss, and he was the first person to renege in a game of spades.
有Haverford Bliss，他是第一个在黑桃牌游戏中违约的人。
You know what? I don't even play spades. I just know that that is a bad thing, I think. [LAUGHS]
你知道吗？我甚至不玩黑桃牌。我只是知道那是一件坏事，我想。[笑]
That's right. There was also George G. Money Spencer, who was the first-- [LAUGHS] he was the first person to end every sentence with, "it is what it is."
没错。还有George G. Money Spencer，他是第一个——[笑] 他是第一个每句话都以“It is what it is”结尾的人。
Hmm. AKA, the patron saint of reality shows. Because they say that all the time.
嗯。AKA，现实秀的守护神。因为他们总是这么说。
Exactly.
正是如此。
At the end of the day, it is what it is.
归根结底，It is what it is。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Another great one-- Tracy and I are friends now, but I was a fan first. A big fan. What makes her comedy so good is her incredible observation skills. She works from a position of what the southern writer Kiese Layman calls "black abundance." Her references come from her own black American experience, growing up in Louisville, Kentucky, as well as wider culture. She marries high concept to the very silly, and Little Known Black History Facts was just one of the many things she created.
另一个很棒的——Tracy和我是朋友，但我首先是粉丝。大粉丝。让她喜剧效果那么好的原因是她令人难以置信的观察能力。她从南方作家Kiese Layman所称的“黑人富足”的位置出发。她的参考来自于她自己的美国黑人经历，在肯塔基州路易斯维尔长大，以及更广泛的文化。她把高概念和非常愚蠢结合在一起，“鲜为人知的黑人历史事实”只是她创造的众多东西之一。
Tracy is a one-woman production line of golden internet content. That gifted brain of hers spots delights and amplifies it. In fact, it felt like Tracy's entire life was about cultivating glee. And then, seemingly at the height of her powers, she just stopped making stuff. She lost her ability to feel delight.
Tracy是一个人的金牌互联网内容生产线。她那天才的大脑捕捉到快乐并放大它。事实上，感觉Tracy的一生都在培养欢乐。然后，似乎在她的权力巅峰，她停止了制造东西。她失去了感受快乐的能力。
I felt like I was laying on the bottom of the ocean floor and looking up, and I could see like the sun, and people on the beach somehow, but I'm just miles, and miles, and leagues, and leagues away from it.
我感觉自己躺在海洋底部抬头看着，我可以看得到太阳，还有海滩上的人，但我距离它有几英里、几英里，几里、几里远。
Things got really bad for Tracy, and for her that was extreme, because delight wasn't just a job, it was also her identity. This is a story of what happened when things went dark for Tracy, and how she made it back to a place of delight. In 2015, Tracy and her friend, Heben Nigatu, began making a weekly podcast with BuzzFeed, called Another Round.
Tracy的情况变得非常糟糕，对她来说那是极端的，因为快乐不仅仅是工作，它也是她的身份。这是一个关于Tracy变黑暗时发生了什么，以及她如何回到快乐之地的故事。2015年，Tracy和她的朋友Heben Nigatu开始与BuzzFeed制作一个每周播客，叫“Another Round”。
Hi, everyone. I'm Heben.
大家好。我是Heben。
I'm Tracy. And welcome to another round with Heben and Tracy.
我是Tracy。欢迎来到Heben和Tracy的另一轮。
[POPPING SOUNDS]
[爆裂声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What was that?
那是什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There was nothing else like it at the time, two black women trading witty banter, and talking about the stuff that was important to them fueled by their natural chemistry, and, of course, given the name of the show, a good amount of booze. Another Round did so much so well-- interviews with academics, comedians, and MacArthur geniuses, like Lin Manuel Miranda and Nikole Hannah-Jones. They even interviewed then presidential candidate, Hillary Clinton.
当时没有其他像这样的节目，两个黑人女性交换诙谐的谈话，谈论对她们重要的东西，以她们自然的化学反应为动力，当然，鉴于节目的名字，有相当多的酒。“Another Round”做了很多好东西——对学者、喜剧演员和麦克阿瑟天才，如Lin Manuel Miranda和Nikole Hannah-Jones的采访。她们甚至采访了当时的总统候选人Hillary Clinton。
But that was only part of it. Their show was funny, intellectual, thoughtful, and also deeply brilliantly silly. I loved their quizzes. One of Heben's masterpieces was a multiple choice quiz on fake names, or as she put it--
但这只是其中的一部分。她们的节目风趣、睿智、深思熟虑，也深刻地、出色地愚蠢。我喜欢她们的测试。Heben的杰作之一是一个关于假名字的多项选择测试，或者正如她所说的——
Is This A White Man's Name Or Just Some Syllables I Mashed Together, British Edition.
这是白人的名字还是我胡乱拼凑的一些音节，英国版。
British people already have super weird names.
英国人已经有超级奇怪的名字了。
They're just doing the most already anyway. [LAUGHS]
他们无论如何已经做到极致了。[笑]
In this quiz, Tracy had to guess which of the names Heben was reading belonged to an actual real person.
在这个测试中，Tracy必须猜Heben读的名字中哪些属于真正的真人。
All right. Frimfram Fiddlesworth.
好的。Frimfram Fiddlesworth。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Primpram Willoughby.
Primpram Willoughby。
I quit.
我不干了。
Tristram Hunt. Rimram Pendleton.
Tristram Hunt。Rimram Pendleton。
I'm going to say it's one of the last two. I vote for Tristram.
我投后两个之一。我投Tristram。
You're correct! Oh, my god! Tracy, I'm so proud of you!
你对了！哦，天哪！Tracy，我为你感到骄傲！
Another Round was a hit. They were doing live shows, selling out venues across the country and abroad. They won awards. They sold merchandise. Heben and Tracy were being recognized by fans in the street. As it grew, the show was getting more demanding to make. It needed more money, more staff, more time, and they weren't getting any of that.
“Another Round”是一个热门节目。她们在做现场表演，全国各地和国外场地售罄。她们赢得了奖项。她们卖商品。Heben和Tracy被街上的粉丝认出来了。随着节目的成长，制作它变得越来越苛刻。它需要更多的钱，更多的员工，更多的时间，而她们什么都没得到。
Then Heben left BuzzFeed. She took a job at The Late Show with Stephen Colbert, and came back to record new episodes when she could. But things weren't the same. Tracy understood, but it was still hard on both of them.
然后Heben离开了BuzzFeed。她在Stephen Colbert的“深夜秀”找了一份工作，回来尽可能地录制新剧集。但情况不再一样了。Tracy理解，但这对她们俩来说仍然很难。
We didn't have a good way to manage that transition. And I think that since I was the only one in the building who was accessible all the time, a lot of the work fell on me and my shoulders. I'm happy to do the work, but I got tired and didn't know it, you know? I would wake up, like, oh, my god. Again. You know? I can't do this, but I'm doing it anyway.
我们没有很好的方式管理那个过渡。而且我认为，既然我是楼里唯一一直可以访问的人，很多工作落在了我和我的肩上。我很乐意做这份工作，但我累了却不知道，你知道吗？我会起床，像，哦，天哪。又来了。你知道吗？我做不到，但我还是在做。
I was working at BuzzFeed during this time, and ended up co-hosting three episodes, sitting in for either Tracy or Heben. There's one episode in particular that really sticks in my mind.
那时我在BuzzFeed工作，最终共同主持了三集，代替Tracy或Heben。有一集我记得特别清楚。
So everyone, Heben sends all of her love from the very, very, very top and bottom of her heart. She is going to be back soon. She's still busy making magic and stuff with Mr. Colbert. But in the meantime and in between time, we've got a Bim in the studio!
所以大家，Heben从她心底的最深处传达了她所有的爱。她很快就会回来。她还在忙着和Colbert先生创造魔法之类的。但在此期间，我们在工作室里有了一个Bim！
[VOCALIZING]
[练声]
(SINGING) Bim in the studio!
（唱歌）Bim in the studio!
My shoulders are working!
我的肩膀在动！
Hit them with the shoulders!
用肩膀撞击它们！
[SCATTING]
[散射声]
It was a ridiculous time.
那是一段荒谬的时光。
That seems like so much fun.
那看起来太有趣了。
It was the funnest episode. And I think afterwards, I was talking to you, and it was like, OK, well, we finished that up. We're done recording. And I was like, so what are you up to for the rest of the day? And you said, back to bed for a depression nap. The minute the mic went off, you were like, all right. I'm out.
那是最好玩的一集。而且我想之后，我在和你说话，就像，好的，好吧，我们完成了。我们录音完了。我问，你今天剩下的时间要干什么？你说，回床上睡抑郁觉。麦克风关掉的那一刻，你说，好的。我走了。
Yeah, yeah. Back to my real life. That's very true.
是的，是的。回到我的现实生活。这是真的。
You remember that at all?
你记得那个吗？
No, not that. I mean, I remember that episode and that stuff, but I don't remember the depression nap stuff. And I think that's because I was depressed, and your memory it's not there. Also, when everyday feels like another day, and another day, I couldn't even tell you what year that happened. But it sounds about right. I feel like that's the theme for a pretty long period of my life.
不，那个不记得。我是说，我记得那一集和那些东西，但我记不住抑郁觉之类的东西。我想那是因为我抑郁了，你的记忆它不在那里。而且，当每一天感觉就像又一天，又一天，我甚至不能告诉你那发生在哪一年。但这听起来很对。我觉得那是很长一段生活的主题。
Listening back to the episodes of the show that aired during this dark period, it's hard to discern that anything was amiss. And that's because Tracy proved to be adept at employing that age-old showbiz trick-- she faked it.
回听在这个黑暗时期播出的节目，很难看出有什么不对劲。那是因为Tracy被证明擅长使用那个老派的表演技巧——她假装了。
Having to fake the funk, as it were, was driven mostly by, I can't let other people down. And it was also like muscle memory, I guess. I'm really, really, really good at smalltalk.
不得不假装，很大程度上是由于，我不能让其他人失望。这也有点像肌肉记忆，我想。我真的很擅长闲聊。
When you are faking delight, do you feel delight? Does it bleed into it?
当你假装快乐时，你感到快乐吗？它会渗透进去吗？
Yeah. I would get lost and caught up in the conversation. So I did have chances to get carried away. The effects were not long-term, but it did give me a nice little break, little pockets of OK-ness here and there. But I tell you what, as soon as the interviews and stuff were over, stepping out of the studio, it was just like I had gone 12 rounds with Tyson.
是的。我会迷失并沉浸在对话中。所以我确实有机会被带走。效果不是长期的，但它确实给了我一个小小的休息，这里那里一点点的OK。但我告诉你，采访之类的东西一结束，走出工作室，感觉就像我刚和Tyson打了12轮。
The show eventually went on hiatus. Tracy went on disability. At first it was a relief to just stay home. Leaving the house would have meant dealing with New York-- the noise, the people, the subway. But then Tracy realized she was staying in because she was afraid to leave her apartment.
节目最终暂停了。Tracy去残疾了。起初呆在家里是一种解脱。离开家意味着要处理纽约——噪音，人，地铁。但后来Tracy意识到她呆在家里是因为她害怕离开公寓。
This one time I was supposed to go somewhere. I was all dressed. Somehow, by the grace of God, and whoever else was watching, I was dressed. I looked decent. I didn't look depressed, quote, unquote. And I got to the door of my apartment, and I thought about the trek on the subway. And I was like, I can't. And I didn't go out. I put myself through all of that, getting dressed. It had taken hours for this to happen.
有一次我本该去某个地方。我穿得整整齐齐。不知怎么的，靠上帝的恩典，和任何其他人关注着，我穿好了。我看起来不错。我看起来不像抑郁，所谓。我到了公寓门口，我想到地铁的跋涉。我心想，我不能。我没出去。我经历了这一切，穿好衣服。这花了几个小时。
And I'm fighting with myself. Be kind to yourself. It's OK if your eyebrows don't match. It's OK if it's taking you four hours to get ready. Just do it. And then, by the time I got to the door, I expended so much energy getting myself together, I cannot also expend energy trying to make my brain focus on which stop do I get off of?
我自己在和自己斗争。对自己好点。如果眉毛不对称没关系。如果花四个小时准备也没关系。去做吧。然后，当我到了门口，我为了让自己在一起花费了太多的精力，我不能再花费精力去让我的大脑集中在我在哪一站下车？
She did less and less, and the fact that she was doing less made her feel even worse. She turned her quick, talented mind inwards, turned herself into a target, and was relentless at attacking herself. She couldn't turn it off. Tracy stopped cleaning her apartment, barely changed clothes.
她做得越来越少，而她做得越来越少的事实让她感觉更糟糕。她把她快速、有才华的大脑向内，把自己变成了一个目标，并不断地攻击自己。她不能关掉它。Tracy停止打扫公寓，几乎不换衣服。
I just remembered being in my room on my bed. The entire place is a mess. And I was just laying and I was thinking about how nobody knows that right now, this is where I am. And I remember getting my phone to text my friend Teddy, who live in Louisville. And I was just like, I'm having a tough time and I just need somebody to know it.
我只记得在床上呆在房间里。整个地方是一团糟。我只是躺着，我想没有人知道此时此刻，这就是我在哪里。我记得拿出手机给住在路易斯维尔的朋友Teddy发短信。我只是说，我正在度过一段艰难的时光，我只是需要有人知道。
And he was very gracious. He was like, I'm glad that you reached out. And I know it now, but-- I don't know. There was something about just wanting somebody to know that you're sad. That I was like, wow, I'm really sad.
他很客气。他说，我很高兴你联系了我。我现在知道了，但……我不知道。只是想要有人知道你很难过这件事本身就有某种东西。我就像，哇，我真的很难过。
After almost a year of feeling truly terrible, Tracy had something that felt like a breakthrough. It started with a ritual she'd been doing every night for months.
在经历了近一年的真正糟糕的感觉后，Tracy有了一个感觉像是突破的东西。它始于一个她几个月来每晚都在做的仪式。
Oh, there was this moment when I realized that Otis Redding's "Sitting On The Dock of the Bay" is about depression. And I was like, oh, my gosh! This entire time? Are you kidding me? I thought it was some old man song about fishing, because I only knew the chorus. But the words, oh, my gosh. "Sitting on the dock of the bay, watching the tide roll away." Yeah. Just wasting time. Just like nothing else to do, nowhere else to go.
哦，有这样一个时刻，我意识到Otis Redding的“Sitting On The Dock of the Bay”是关于抑郁的。我就像，哦，天哪！整个时间？你在开玩笑吗？我以为那是一首关于钓鱼的老男人歌，因为我只知道副歌。但歌词，哦，天哪。“坐在海湾码头上，看着潮水滚去。”是的。只是浪费时间。什么都没做，无处可去。
So Tracy had a playlist of sad songs, including "Sitting On The Dock Of The Bay," and every night around 9:00 PM, she'd stand at the window of her apartment, smoking, and drinking, and looking down at the street, feeling like a caricature of a sad girl.
所以Tracy有一个悲伤歌曲的播放列表，包括“Sitting On The Dock Of The Bay”，每天晚上9:00左右，她都会站在公寓窗前，抽烟，喝酒，看着街道，感觉自己像个悲伤女孩的漫画。
And this one night, after however many months of this ritual, I just started to dance. First, it was a little sway to whatever song was playing. It may have been the Otis Redding song, because, I mean, it's got a little-- (SINGING AND SNAPPING ALONG IN TIME) Sitting on the dock of the bay, wasting time. You know? You can two step a little bit to it. And after that I was like, maybe I want to listen to other things to dance to.
这个晚上，在这仪式的几个月后，我只是开始跳舞。起初，是对播放的任何歌曲的一点摇摆。那可能是那首Otis Redding的歌，因为，我的意思是，它有点——（跟着节奏唱歌和打响指）Sitting on the dock of the bay, wasting time. 你知道吗？你可以对着它跳两步。在那之后，我想，也许我想听点别的跳舞。
And so, I switched to a different playlist. Couldn't tell you what it was. And I think I danced for an hour-- danced, and smoked, and just drank. And it felt good, and I was smiling, and I was confused. But I was like, don't pick it apart. And also, I could feel how ridiculous I probably looked. Because, I mean, it's not like I was two-stepping the whole time, right?
所以，我换了另一个播放列表。不能告诉你那是什么。我想我跳了一个小时——跳舞，抽烟，只是喝酒。那感觉很好，我在笑，我很困惑。但我心想，别拆解它。而且，我也能感觉到我看起来可能有多可笑。因为，我的意思是，并不是我一直在跳两步，对吧？
It was just some weird interpretive, can this muscle still move? Can I still do a backbend? I cannot. I learned that. [LAUGHS] But it felt-- I don't know, it almost felt like my body was trying to reach my brain somehow. Because it wasn't my brain that told my body to start dancing, I'm pretty sure. I think my body was like, you know what? You know who I haven't talked to in a long time? The brain. Let me check in with the brain and see how things are going. Oh, terribly? Well, let's dance a little bit.
那只是一些奇怪的解释，这块肌肉还能动吗？我还能做后弯吗？我不能。我学到了。[笑] 但它感觉——我不知道，它几乎感觉我的身体在试图以某种方式接触我的大脑。因为不是我的大脑告诉我的身体开始跳舞，我很确定。我想我的身体就像，你知道吗？你知道谁我很久没说话了吗？大脑。让我和大脑核对一下，看看情况如何。哦，很糟糕？好吧，我们跳一点舞吧。
During these months, she also looked at professionals, and she chose a couple who looked like her, understood her.
在这几个月里，她也寻找了专业人士，她选了几个看起来像她、理解她的人。
They are all-- and when I say "all" I mean both my therapist and my psychiatrist-- don't know how it happened, but they are both black women.
她们都是——当我说是“全部”时，我是说我的治疗师和精神科医生——不知道怎么发生的，但她们都是黑人女性。
Yay.
耶。
They will both do-- not interviews-- sessions online. So I didn't have to move-- leave my house when I couldn't. I didn't have to put on pants when I couldn't. One day I got emotional because I woke up late and I forgot about my appointment. So I'm on the little Skype or whatever, I had my bonnet on. And I was like, I'm so sorry that I still have this bonnet on. I know it's not professional. And my therapist said, it's OK. I wear one too. And I was like, every black girl should know what this is, you know? And since then I just show up in my bonnet, like, what's up?
她们都会做——不是采访——在线会话。所以我不需要动——离开我的房子当我不能的时候。我不必穿裤子当我不能的时候。有一天我变得情绪化，因为我起晚了，忘了我的预约。所以我拿着小Skype之类的，我戴着帽子。我心想，我很抱歉我还戴着这顶帽子。我知道它不专业。我的治疗师说，没关系。我也戴。我就像，每个黑人女孩都应该知道这是什么，你知道吗？从那以后我就戴着帽子出现，就像，怎么了？
Eventually, sometime last year, Tracy found herself asking variations of the same question. She thinks Heben might have mentioned it. It was this-- is there anything good that your depression has given you? It sounded perverse, but she couldn't stop thinking about it, couldn't stop mulling the question. And she found that thinking about the answers made her feel good. When she mentioned it to her therapist, she told Tracy that finding something good in a bad situation could be a good sign of healing.
最终，去年某时候，Tracy发现自己问了相同问题的变体。她想Heben可能提到过。就是这个——抑郁给你带来的任何好处吗？这听起来有点反常，但她无法停止思考，无法停止琢磨这个问题。她发现思考答案让她感觉很好。当她告诉她的治疗师时，她告诉Tracy，在坏情况中找到好东西可能是康复的一个好迹象。
And I was like, sounds fake, but what do you mean? She was like, she said the thing really helps you connect with your emotions. But I don't know what that means. I don't know what it means to connect with an emotion. I feel it. I recognize it. I don't want it. I don't like it. I'm ignoring it. I guess that's what she means.
我就像，听起来是假的，但你的意思是什么？她说这件事确实能帮你联系你的情绪。但我不知道那意味着什么。我不知道联系情绪是什么意思。我感受它。我识别它。我不想要它。我不喜欢它。我忽略它。我想那就是她意思的东西。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I think you're answering the question.
我想你在回答这个问题。
All right. I can check that off my to-do list.
好的。我可以把那个从我的待办事项清单上划掉。
So with the question in mind, Tracy started rising in a brand new journal, not unlike Ross Gay's book of delights. She calls it a gratitude journal, which sounds earnest. And yes, she's aware, not very cool. It's a simple practice. A couple of times a week, she writes down what she's grateful for. When she started, she didn't have much faith.
所以带着这个问题，Tracy开始在一个全新的日记里书写，不像Ross Gay的快乐之书。她称它为感恩日记，听起来很真诚。是的，她知道，不是很酷。这是一个简单的练习。一周几次，她写下她感谢的东西。她开始时，没什么信心。
A few months ago, I'd have been like, this is just the most ridiculous-- you know? It's not going to work. People were like, get up and walk around the block, and you won't be depressed. Yes, I will. And eventually this gratitude journal is going to turn into a chore, another thing that I can't keep up. That has not happened at all. It really helps to remember good things that happen to you.
几个月前，我会觉得，这是最荒谬的——你知道吗？它不会起作用。人们就像，起来绕街区走走，你就不会抑郁了。是的，我会。最终这本感恩日记会变成一个家务活，另一件我跟不上的事。那根本没发生。记住发生在你身上的好事情真的很有帮助。
It's been shockingly effective. In his delight essayette, "Bird Feeding," the poet Ross Gay witnesses a man feeding a pigeon in the park. Less than 30 seconds later, he watches another bird-- a tufted tit mouse this time-- swoop down into the hand of a different, wholly unconnected person. A lovely moment twice over. But he wouldn't have noticed that second bird, he said, if the first bird hadn't prepared him to see it.
它非常有效。在他的快乐随笔小品“鸟类喂食”中，诗人Ross Gay见证了一个男人在公园喂鸽子。不到30秒后，他看着另一只鸟——这次是一只簇状山雀——俯冲进一个不同、完全没有联系的人的手里。两次都很可爱的时刻。但他说，如果不是第一只鸟让他准备好看它，他不会注意到第二只鸟。
Tracy's fans thought of her as their first bird, not only a delightful person by herself, but also a doorway to more delight. Now, she's figuring out how to be her own first bird, to develop a system to do for herself what had previously come naturally. Tracy's back at work. She's making new podcasts, interviewing people, being hilarious. She's not faking it.
Tracy的粉丝认为她是他们的第一只鸟，不仅是一个本身快乐的人，而且是通向更多快乐的门口。现在，她在想办法成为她自己的第一只鸟，开发一个系统来为自己做以前自然而然发生的事情。Tracy回到工作岗位了。她在做新播客，采访人们，变得非常有趣。她不是在假装。
When her mom calls with her four-year-old great nephew Jayden, she's able to pick up the phone, even if it's hard at first sometimes.
当她妈妈带着她四岁的侄孙Jayden打电话时，她能接电话，即使有时起初很难。
She'd call, I'd answer the phone. I'm like, yeah, not doing great. I want to get off the phone. She was like, OK. And then she calls Jayden in, and I'm just like, oh. Because he's got so much energy! When I don't have the energy, he still has the energy. So sometimes I'm just like, get this kid away from me! And I loved him, love him to death, but I just couldn't do it in times of high stress.
她会打来，我会接电话。我就像，是的，不太好。我想挂断电话。她说，好的。然后她叫Jayden进来，我就像，哦。因为他有太多的能量！当我没有能量时，他仍然有能量。所以有时我就像，让这个孩子离开我！我爱他，爱死他了，但我只是在压力很大的时候做不到。
And the first thing he says when sees me is, oh, hey, Tracy. [LAUGHS] Like I just interrupted him from doing something. His important four-year-old duties. Hey, Jayden. How are you doing? Blah, blah, blah, blah. And then my mom will go, ask her the question. And then I'm just like, ugh, I don't feel like it. But then he said, OK, I have a question. And then I'm like, what's your question, Jayden? Why are you so cute? [LAUGHS]
他看到我说的第一件事是，哦，嘿，Tracy。[笑] 就像我刚刚打断了他做某事。他重要的四岁职责。嘿，Jayden。你怎么样？吧啦吧啦。然后我妈妈会说，问她那个问题。然后我就像，唉，我不想。但随后他说，好的，我有一个问题。然后我就像，你的问题是什么，Jayden？你为什么这么可爱？[笑]
And I instantly just perk up and smile. I know what the question is going to be. I know I still don't have an answer. And I know, even as he's saying it, I'm just like, it's not going to work. But as soon as he says it, I'm just like, I don't know, man! Why you so cute? I don't know! Being able to deal with family and a hugely energetic child is definitely a sign of mama's coming back. Sophia home now.
我瞬间精神焕发并微笑。我知道问题会是什么。我知道我仍然没有答案。而且我知道，甚至在他说话时，我就像，没用的。但一旦他说出来，我就像，我不知道，伙计！你为什么这么可爱？我不知道！能够处理家庭和一个非常有活力的孩子绝对是妈妈回来的标志。Sophia home now.
Was that a Color Purple reference?
那是紫色之色的参考吗？
It was.
是。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This is the blackest This American Life has ever been.
这是This American Life最黑人的一次。
[LAUGHTER] Sophia home now. What?
[笑声] Sophia home now. 什么？
Tracy Clayton is the host of the podcast Strong Black Legends.
Tracy Clayton是播客Strong Black Legends的主持人。
Our program today was produced by me and Dana Chivvis. Our staff includes Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Nora Gale, Damien Gray, Michelle Harris, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raymondo, Ben Falen, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们今天的节目是由我和Dana Chivvis制作的。我们的员工包括Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Nora Gale, Damien Gray, Michelle Harris, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raymondo, Ben Falen, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, 和 Nancy Updike。我们的管理编辑是Diane Wu。我们的执行编辑是David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks today to Heben Nigatu, Michael Mackenzie, Emily Miles, Ethan Fried, Amy Marsalla, and Joanna Kagan. Our website is thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks to my boss, Ira Glass, who guided me as I hosted the show this week. He really got stuck in.
今天特别感谢Heben Nigatu, Michael Mackenzie, Emily Miles, Ethan Fried, Amy Marsalla, 和 Joanna Kagan。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。This American Life通过PRX，公共广播交易所，发送到公共广播电台。感谢我的老板Ira Glass，他在本周主持节目时指导了我。他真的被困住了。
Though it did get a little annoying when he brought his soup into the studio.
虽然当他把汤带进工作室时确实有点烦人。
I'm Bim Adewunmi. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Bim Adewunmi。Ira Glass下周会带着更多This American Life的故事回来。